[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
salle base et qui est magnifique je
retiens je vais dire des choses mon
genre je m'en fous global je balance sa
grâce
sa part tiré l'attention
tout cas tu as à faire tout problème
à partir de là tu peux avoir ça va faire
tout drôle
c'est que c'est très bien ce que je veux
dire il ferait ainsi qu'une vidéo alors
il a commencé à une maintenant
[Applaudissements]
et elle se trouve actuellement dans les
locaux
c'est pas vrai alors il ya le dell bien
sûr nouvelle team et nous montre comme
ça que je fais comme ça donc là il entra
montre un technicien donc
passé
mais c'est vous
ce couple est
chez les filles cette mascarade
je vais voir revellat l'avoir cette
salade c'est l'un des modèles
commencèrent à cebu pas c'était ya là
mais est il ya trois mois le bar alors
franchement les mecs je suis étonné
comme quoi les chiens ne font pas des
chats
[Applaudissements]
seba sujet la bonne expression non mais
mais bon ah ouais alors allé très bonne
idée
magnifique avec ses voisines que sont le
maître des lieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau il a ramené à 9 quand on
amène sanofi si wes etc sans éclat y est
ça commence regardez-moi daniel au début
de la cacher
riquet dit ça y est on y va on sort
daniel et là c'est parti c'est monsieur
daniel du couple anne on n'arrive pas à
tuer le topless franchement très très
belle très très joli oui mais c'est bon
monsieur le réalisateur
s'appelle emma eiffage anormalement bas
on embrasse evans ou non non non non
paris
croire et c'est comme ça heureusement
dix mois monsieur réalisateur on a
compris maintenant c'est ok alors elle
s'appelle iba et unac aux rencontres et
comment comment j'ai rencontré en
général a foutu trois patates crowley
je vous raconte d'après syrie
à lui à moscou ont dévissé une connerie
je suis de trois questions et on s'est
rencontrés étaient légères moore gt gt a
dans un autre pays en espagne à madrid
je montrais mon cul dans la rue non
alors vous les conneries que vous
faisait sur comédie cherche un peu mais
c'est vrai mais c'est loin mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai et c'est dit
celui là peut-être qu'il est drôle et du
coup bah voilà alors c'est bien connu on
est ce parce qu'ils trouvent elles
habitent ou comment elle entre la france
et l'espagne chez elle vagabonde et pour
la faire venir le tour de la terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bah j'ai cioccolato quoi lever votre
masque
à la série et 20 kg est là l'amoureuse
depuis son jeune âge tu expliques la
chronique tu peux te la photo puis
[Applaudissements]
moi je te le dis moi eh bah alors où
avez vous rencontré sacha et bien entre
eux entre la france et l'espagne c'est
vrai véridique mais
ça vient dire que j'étais à fond sur le
magnifique
qu'il arrive je vais vous dire je vais
sauter cette phrase de franck mickaël
qu'ils aient toutes les femmes sont
belles
bâtisses maman je compte et en parler
mais
franchement
vous êtes encore plus belle sans le
masquer ce qui n'est pas le cas de tout
le monde
mais le masque oui mais mathieu ça fait
un choc ça
ça on dise est une comme quoi je vais
tenir mathieu la télé nivelles
et si les mêmes personnes ça ringard
avait tout il avait 33 personnes
tronquoy ouais bah alors est-ce que ça
fait combien de temps que avec sacha
[Applaudissements]
1h20 servent étroitement trois quatre
mois cueillie chacha savez truc à lui un
flash pour lui flash direct après c'est
vrai quand même pas mal comment tu l'as
vu où tu l'as vu en espagne dans la rue
j'ai couru j'ai cherché non ça c'est pas
exactement passé comme ça lui ira gay ou
c'est toi va évidemment se dit oui c'est
un mytho mais quelle bientôt olalala eva
c'est ce que je vais faire je vais je
veux que tu restes pendant la chronique
de ton mec fait maths à côté
voilà par serrières le débat quel label
retour à son cadre remercié cet
anniversaire c'est rire alors il prend
plein d'oseille tu peux y aller
je te rappelle que la saint-valentin
lundi d'ailleurs j'ai un peu on peut se
parler
[Applaudissements]
je trouve qu'il allait beaucoup mieux
ensemble
non mais sans déconner c'est pas la
question s'il est prouvé mais dont on te
l'a poussé à bord et ont récemment on
peut voir ça j'ai une photo de mars
alors tu vas pour les portables bien tu
l'aimé bien c'est prenez en photo des
femmes ça peut arriver non non non je
suis tout seul vélo recèle fils et sa
fille normale dans la salle d'eau 1
c'était pour eux sport and fitness
[Rires]
je veux commencer ou à parler de ma vie
privée et
3,4 me faisais attention est ce que il
embrasse bien
gardé
ils apparaissent bien il en reste très
bien non mais j'ai à ma mère qui regarde
mon père ou sa mère photo rb on peut
s'embrasser pensée du cylisme à
dire aujourd'hui tout le monde faire des
chars des snacks à tout le monde
aujourd'hui c'est rien du tout gardez
castagnou pouvait faire un smack à
beinheim
médecin-patient combats s'y associer les
bush fils en fou
mais s'arrête c'est comme si tu
embrasses à bonbons
mathieu tu peux faire regardez ici à
beinheim ali qua non de beinheim à
lézignan
[Rires]
vous
c'est vrai tout le monde peut faire des
paquets tout le monde il dans l'amour on
est dans le partage regarder castaldi
oui voilà
là vous ne pouvez pas au loup blanc
parce qu'on met pas patoche n'aurais pas
fait tout pour quoi on mettrait à ma
copine c'est une torture et faire ce que
tu dis déjà très vite en forme et parce
que pato c'est pas toi j'étais la siphat
est là l
habitat il a l'habitude avec le micro
j'habite à madrid j'adore sacha le
basque est ce qu'aujourd'hui mon châssis
réel on commence avec arié tout sur vous
que j'étais obligé est ce que vous
considérez plutôt dans la catégorie des
gentils ou des mes chiens écoutez je
vais vous dire on peut demander ici
benjamin gentil merci beinheim mes
chantiers lancés magnéto
j'ai bientôt les talons josy merci jean
champ à
exceptionnel
bien sûr ça compte double aujourd'hui
aux
gentils très méchant
n'est ce pas payer
me prononce pas encore à bas coûts ce
qui s'est produit merci
dre remarqué chez vous on voit que les
nouveaux viennent d'arriver
et bien moi ses lettres je n'arrive pas
trop à juger mais vous savez ce qu'on
dit dans le milieu mettre un petit
bâtard bah écoute
[Rires]
et bong su ça va plus dégueulasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je dis non c'est vous venez
pour le jardin
les émaux j-100 inventé par ou en tout
cas sont décidés par apple et par la
silicon valley la silicon valley où
on est méchant méchant coup droit qu'est
ce qui se passe lentement les mais vous
allez refaire la ferme célébrités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi tu marches comme si tu avais
une cuisse de poulet gratuit
on est méchant et les sens j'aime mieux
le rejet de 2022 mais c'est vrai que
c'est maintenant et comme quoi ya pas de
règles
elle a un beau petit monde se retrouve
avec bouvier
il ya une règle d'or dans cette émission
du monde nous rejoigne à
19h48
et des poussières
à baba je ne mentirai jamais
malheureusement on finit un menteur ce
vieil adage n'a pas été respect
pas été respectée par une personne ici
bas
cette personne n'est pas là où fera non
elle et l'a
fait pour la seule base
mahdi droit dans les yeux nous a dit à
tous un clubic autre chroniqueur à la
france qui nous regardent oui la france
d'en haut et la france d'en bas la
france 2 partout
laura dee droit dans les yeux qu'il
avait rencontré eva sa petite amie en
espagne à mettre seulement d' c'est une
énorme supercherie
eva habite bien en espagne mais il a
rencontré ici même dans le public
j'ai les infos et les infos je le sais
je sais tout ça challes base
ajustée j'aurais pas j'aurais pas aimé
connaître il ya quelques années mokhtar
emmené le
[Applaudissements]
okada peut être quelqu'un sonne à lire
l'article j'ai peut-être quelque chose à
dire bota bota pour l'instant si toi vas
te faire via quelques briques
[Rires]
c'est incroyable mathieu je sais que tu
es déçu alors comment avez vous pu vous
mentir les yeux dans les yeux j'ai vu ce
qu'on a que c'était un petit menteur à
vous à nous
du tout c'est hélas dénoncé la vérité
non j'ai marché de tanger en droit de
réponse soit oui c'est la vérité at il
pas du tout vous savez que je ne vous
mentirai jamais et je ne mentirai jamais
aux téléspectateurs quel menteur déjà
s'être
laissée aux rires alors pas du tout
jamais je regarde mes très chers voilà
c'est quoi ta version ma version allait
très clair ouais lors d'un week end en
espagne à madrid entre de tapas
départ et une arrivée
eva avila sa copine quand je les ai vus
comme une lumière je me suis mise
monsieur et demi à la draguer et au
final je les paie chaud
je prends tes affaires ne
s'est pas tu dégages à l'université
vite
merci les séries garcia va merci va dire
il ment il ment
nouveau lundi noir de surchaussures
grave il reviendra quand il avoir oui
voilà non mais franchement theory
actionnariat public ci aura et non c'est
pas sûr non pas du tout
mais qui nous dit oui je le dis parce
que c'est la
libre à guelma
moi eh ben moi c'est moi c'est là à la
jeune femme à côté
et ben voilà bah comme quoi voilà chaque
année en mai chez bach et en vue
d'actions pour un sachet en par quoi il
y aura des sanctions ouais ouais si ça
fait
il sera très prochainement dans tpm
people
[Rires]
la sanction ultime a
entendu chez les
centres eu beau mano et pascal bataille
et laurent fontaine
alors alexandre non mais c'est pas la
peine de rester à
l'hfr chabat
merci si ses parents qui nous regardent
ils peuvent commencer le qui touche au
vert sinon alors je dis cela ce thème en
sont issues a cédé en colère ou déçu
pour l'instant je suis rentré je suis
venu vous avez raison
franchement entre les deux j'attends de
voir comment il va réagir mais il a
continué à mentir métier à temps à la
première fois ces primo parce que c'est
apple propulsif c'est en lui quoi il est
fier mais sans lui il vit sans lui c'est
vrai ce père fun pour gérer vous avec
daniel boyer ou pas voilà moi je n'ai
rien à voir quel sort lui l'allemand son
jeu